it is over the shortest serving prime
minister stepping down
I came into office at a time of great
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
a mandate which slipped away after just
six weeks I recognize though given the
situation I cannot deliver the Mandate
on which I was elected by the
conservative party I have therefore
spoken to his majesty the king to notify
him that I am resigning as leader of the
conservative party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
turning her back on an embattled
Premiership only her husband by her side
this a very lonely way to leave
sir gray and Brady the man charged with
the next steps here police agree I'm
here please to Graeme setting out the
direction of the party and Country too
I have spoken to the party chairman Jake
Berry and he has confirmed that it will
be possible to conduct a ballot and
conclude the leadership election
by Friday the 28th of October so we
should have a new leader in place
before the fiscal statement which will
take place on the 31st a new leadership
contest the second in four months
conducted at Breakneck speed this time
next week we'll have a new PM for the
press and the public too it's
bewildering how disappointed are you in
this the public must be looking at this
thinking what on Earth is going on this
is the governing party absolutely and I
think we're deeply conscious of the
imperative and the national interest of
resolving this uh clearly and quickly
by early evening the detail come into
light conservative MPS have to decide
fast uh good afternoon again uh just to
confirm I've met with the board of the
conservative party and the executive of
the United super committed the process
for the Parliamentary stages of the
contest will begin now nominations are
now open we'll close at two o'clock on
Monday candidates will be expected to
have at least 100
colleagues nominating them a decision to
whittle the field back dramatically if
only one MP hits the threshold we'll
know the new PM by Monday this will be
quick but for labor it's not enough it's
demanding a general election saki your
call in for a general election but at a
moment of acute instability there has
been Market instability there's a cost
of living crisis this the Tories are
going to replace the Prime Minister
within a week
in the general election is going to take
weeks and weeks and weeks can you see
that that might not be practical right
now but the risk to the country is
carrying on with this utter chaos so
you've got this real Choice utter chaos
with the conservatives or stability
under a labor government so the risk is
not a general election the risk is
carrying on with this utter chaos
they've made huge they've damaged the
economy very badly in the last few weeks
this damage has been done
the conservative parties decided we need
a new prime minister Liz truss has been
forced to resign after just 44 days in
office this whole sorry Affair has been
a dark dark chapter for the Tories MPS
are now trying to turn the corner there
will be a new prime minister next week
but the party is having in the words of
one Minister a collective breakdown and
after two lots of vicious blood let him
fast around Boris Johnson and now around
Liz troughs you have to ask yourself
whether a new leader can stop the rot
the sun set in on a deeply unsettling
day in Westminster in these tumultuous
times a nation awaiting leadership Beth
Rigby Sky News Westminster